here's the nightmare the light turns
green it's clear to go through you make
your way down the intersection but out
the corner of your eye and an instant
later there's another notch
added to the thirty thousand deaths from
car crashes a year of which up to twenty
three percent our intersection related
so law enforcement and city officials
all over the country have tried to solve
this problem by installing red-light
cameras to get drivers to slow down stop
and save lives
rather than just blowing through red
lights the ultimate hope is is to
improve safety at the intersection by
reducing traffic crashes there's just
one problem
these cameras don't just stop car
crashes they create others as well since
the 1960's thousands of red-light
cameras have been posted around
intersections across the US and there's
no denying that these cameras really can
and do save lives but they also show an
increase in less deadly rear-end
collisions because of drivers abruptly
stopping to avoid red light tickets and
depending on where cameras are placed
they create more car crashes where there
weren't many or any at all to begin with
crashes at intersections are most often
caused by cars turning left while cars
cross on the opposite side of the road
many tickets are going to drivers who
California roll to turn right on red but
those cars only make up about 1% of
intersection crashes there is of course
another reason beyond safety why cities
would install red light cameras tickets
from real light cameras can cost a
driver between $50 and $500 cities like
Orlando Florida Chicago Illinois and
Washington DC bring in millions of
dollars in fines from red light camera
tickets camera vendors such as red flex
traffic systems American Traffic
Solutions and several others have
incentive to get a lot of contracts
because they take care of the
installation operation and maintenance
of those cameras which in turn cost
cities millions of dollars
in Chicago when ex city official was
convicted in receiving up to two million
dollars in bribes for rare light camera
contracts and in a lawsuit firered flex
executive made 13 other cities that
allegedly participated in receiving
bribes from the traffic camera company
as well if safety were really the
biggest or only concerned there are
alternatives to rely cameras that would
be just as effective and cost less it
would take just a bit more City planning
for example the timing of yellow lights
is key the federal guidelines specified
that yellow lights need only to fall
between three and six seconds but red
light cameras might give cities
incentive to stay on the shorter end of
that range in Florida when intersections
yellow light intervals were adjusted
from three point nine seconds to four
point eight seconds and there was a 79
percent drop in issued citations curb
extensions and speed humps also forced
traffic to slow down
visual cues like Suns are another way to
signal to drivers to be even more aware
of an impending style even the unpopular
roundabout is not only safer than a
four-way or T intersection it also
increases traffic flow efficiency so now
several cities across the u.s. are
rethinking their red light camera
programs and Albuquerque New Mexico
ended their program in 2011 the bottom
line is that this is a company that's
for profit they're gonna make a profit
and and that's what these cameras do